the late 19th century wasn't great for
africa or africans it was when europeans
looked south and decided that africa was
filled with all this unclaimed land and
opted to change that the great powers
all met in berlin in 1885 and hashed out
some rules for grabbing whatever they
could one great nation which attended
this conference yet took no part in the
scramble for africa was the united
states of america which very easily
could have laid claims to lands there if
it wanted to which raises the question
why why didn't the usa take part in the
scramble for africa now during the late
19th century successive u.s presidents
had very different opinions on whether
the united states should build an empire
or oppose imperialism as a matter of
principle some called for the annexation
of cuba alaska santo domingo and hawaii
with only half of those actually
happening when the berlin conference
opened the united states was in an
imperialism isn't for us mood and so its
representatives there proposed a
different plan why don't we only
partially carve up the continent open
its waterways to all nations and make
africa a free trade area the american
ideas were promptly dismissed however
the us did get some concessions in that
the congo would be open to all
international trade which meant that
unlike the parts of africa under the
control of the great european powers the
u.s would have at least some access by
the way this idea of america just
wanting to trade is the theme of late
19th to early 20th century u.s foreign
policy so with that it was decided that
africa would be carved up and the us
opted out for several important reasons
the first was that it already had a lot
of spare land which wasn't densely
populated and had ample resources yet to
be exploited plus by the time the us was
done integrating its westwood lands the
scramble for africa was over meaning
that if they wanted to build an overseas
empire they'd need to take somebody
else's an opportunity which would soon
present itself the second reason was
liberia across the previous century
american patrons had helped to fund
friedman's journeys to africa to found a
territory for freed slaves in 1822 this
culminated in the creation of liberia
which was sort of an american colony but
also totally wasn't as such it just sort
of sat in limbo it eventually got sick
of america ignoring it and it declared
its independence in 1847. however it
maintained very good relations with the
united states and after this alongside
the congo the us had much of the access
to africa for missionaries and trade
that it had wanted the third reason was
that american desire to spread its
influence beyond its own borders was
mostly limited to its neighbors in south
america all of this being under the
monroe doctrine this was a pledge by the
united states to protect the americas in
any independent state there from
european expansion or coercion providing
that you exclude the british claiming
the falklands mexico being run by an
austrian briefly and venezuela seeding
land to britain and so with that the
united states just sort of sat the
scramble for africa out much like their
european cousins the americans were also
interested in the resources and
conversion of africa but unlike
europeans americans felt like they
already had hegemony over two continents
and thus they had no desire to squabble
over pieces of a third i hope you
enjoyed this episode and a special
thanks to my patrons james bisonette
kelly money maker skye chappelle corso
wolff jordan longley adam stalter jerry
lambda marcus arsenault words about
books podcast rodney martin lion hockey
marvin castell spencer lightfoot
boogerly wiggly winston k wood captain
cydol kim moon yoon gustav swan daniel
to be in misses at aaron the white
matthew shipley maggie patzkowski alex
schwinn corey turner anthony beckett
coppertone schwennin spinning three
plates the mcquapper and charles the
first